[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous mardi 29 mai bienvenue
dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 78 tout de
suite les titres de cette édition
c'est un exemple de la reprise des
investissements à saint quentin en
yvelines une entreprise emitech investi
plus de 7 millions d'euros pour étendre
son activité nouveaux locaux nouveaux
équipements pour le groupe qui emploie
150 personnes à montigny le bretonneux
fait réfléchir à l'impact de nos gestes
au quotidien un des objectifs de la
semaine du développement durable voisins
le bretonneux organise l'événement pour
la deuxième fois
au programme ateliers projections
conférences nous en parlons avec
catherine à tahaa maire adjointe à
l'environnement
enfin le président depuis plusieurs
années l'association jardins passions
partage à guyancourt en cpt2 faux
entretien à petit paradis végétal son
jardin parmi les plus beaux du coin
abrite plantes exotiques les fleurs
rares et c'est le portrait de la semaine
dans ce journal nous prendrons également
des nouvelles de l'association élan de
solidarité vélizy depuis plus d'un an
elle vient en aide aux sans abri elle
met d'abord vous n'avez peut-être pas
reçu de courrier aujourd'hui la
distribution a été perturbée par un
mouvement de grève des facteurs est
mobilisation reconductible à l'appel de
la cgt pour dénoncer est la dégradation
des conditions de travail dans le
département sont pointés du doigt
notamment les nombreuses réorganisations
de la poste depuis dix ans et qui
impacterait directement la tournée des
postiers le syndicat parle même de
situation devenue catastrophique dans
certaines communes comme elancourt la
reprise économique se confirme en france
avec notamment une progression de 4,3
pour cent de l'investissement des
entreprises l'an passé exemple à
montigny le bretonneux avec cette
société qui a investi plus de 7 millions
d'euros cette année pour se développer
et mitec est spécialisée dans les essais
de produits avant leur commercialisation
et ses salariés se sont installés début
mai dans leur nouveau bâtiment reportage
de nicolas bandry et clémence dernier un
laboratoire de 6000 mètres carrés des
bureaux administratifs 9 ou encore de
nouvelles machines
un investissement total de près de 8
millions d'euros pour rémy tech
cette entreprise créée en 1989 et
spécialisés
les tests de produits des équipements
grand public à l'industrie aéronautique
automobile ou médicales elle réalise
près de 35 millions de chiffre
d'affaires par an nous avons aujourd'hui
des voitures électriques des voitures
hybrides des véhicules communicants des
véhicules intelligents de plus en plus
d'électronique donc de plus en plus
d'essais à réaliser nous avons investi
des cages de faraday spécifique à
l'électronique automobile
au total et vittek a investi dans huit
nouvelles cages de faraday pour
augmenter la capacité des essais en
compatibilité électromagnétique des
ondes sont envoyés sur l'objet
électronique testé pour observer sa
réaction
on peut avoir par exemple sur un produit
un peu complexe un arrêt de
fonctionnement si on prend une
télévision
la télévision va se brouiller et donc on
peut pas permettre quand une mobylette
passe dans la rue que la télé ce bruit
autre type d'essai la résistance à des
vibrations des chocs ou encore des
secousses des tests liés aussi aux
conditions climatiques réalisé dans ces
huit machines acquise dernièrement pour
un montant total d'environ 300 mille
euros cette enceinte permet de tester
des produits en fonctionnement au world
fonctionnement dans des températures
hautes ou basses puisqu'on peut
descendre à moins 80 moins 100 degrés et
monte à plus 150 en fonction des
machines vraiment tester les équipements
donc tous les
les environnements possible cette
société saint-quentinoise dépend de la
capacité des entreprises à innover
depuis le début de l'année 2018 et mitec
a réalisé près de 20% de croissance
toujours à montigny le bretonneux la
démolition de l'ancien collège bergson
se poursuit pour rappel cet espace
deviendra un pôle culturel avec un
conservatoire de musique théâtre et
danse 140 logements seront également
construits comprenant des parkings
souterrains les précisions sur
l'avancement du chantier
au micro de manon varaldo et patrick
jacques de dixmude les travaux de
désamiantage est en terminer des travaux
de curage étant terminée donc on est
vraiment maintenant en phase de
démolition et donc fin de semaine
prochaine tout le tout le collège sera
démoli il nous restera durant tout le
mois de juin à évacuer donc maintenant
tous les to les bétons et tous les
matériaux qui ont été au préalable
séparées qu'ont fin des travaux prévue
courant 2020 focus à présent sur une
entreprise élan courtoise du paysage et
demi sur l'insertion des personnes en
chômage longue durée un serpro a décidé
de placer l'humain au coeur de son
activité les détails avec ce sujet
d'aurélie ronces christophe à 30 ans
après de nombreux stages et petits
boulots il vient tout juste d'intégrer
l'équipe d'un serpro une entreprise d'
espaces verts basé à elancourt une
véritable opportunité puisque ce contrat
d'ouvriers en insertion va lui permettre
une reconnexion durable avec le monde du
travail par semaine s'est bien passé
j'aime ce que je fais travailler en
extérieur donc ça me plaît donc la
motivation de venir chaque matin un
serpro intervient sur tout l'ouest
parisien pour des entreprises des
promoteurs ou encore des agglomérations
particularité de cette structure depuis
près de 40 ans recruté en majorité des
personnes éloignées de l'emploi
seuls les encadrants sont en cdi une
démarche économique et sociale et
solidaire les personnes en insertion ont
un contrat de quatre mois jusqu'à deux
ans maximum et dans ce laps de temps ont
la possibilité de faire les formations
qui vont les aider à être employés à bhl
et vont pouvoir être intégrer plus
facilement dans la vie active
un peu triste de voir à la fin des deux
ans que le personnage et ont informé
s'en va et mois après ces deux buts dans
sa proue aussi c'est qu'ils retrouvent
du travail après qui s'insère dans la
vie professionnelle et en général c'est
une réussite actuellement sous le statut
d'association interpro pourrait évoluer
en coopérative est ainsi étoffer son
personnel et juste après ce journal
l'émission mode d'emploi sera consacrée
à l'insertion professionnelle et plus
particulièrement au plan local pour
l'insertion et l'emploi de saint quentin
en yvelines le pli qui fête cette année
ses 20 ans l agglomération qui se réunit
ce soir en conseil communautaire on
connaîtra le nom du successeur de
jean-pierre sevestre et qui a remis sa
démission pour raison de santé l'élu
était en charge de la vice présidence de
la collectivité aux sports fin avril
déjà le maire de coignières s'était mis
en retrait de sa commune pour les mêmes
motifs et laissant les affaires
courantes à son adjoint david pelletier
est le nouveau vice président en charge
des sports de saint quentin en yvelines
va récupérer notamment le dossier de
l'organisation de la ryder cup a qui se
déroulera fin septembre
en octobre les militants des
républicains des yvelines devront
choisir leur nouveau président de
fédération pour succéder à david
douillet en lice notamment le duo formé
par la vice-présidente de
l'ile-de-france alexandra du blanche et
le trappistes othman nassr ou dans le
cadre de leur campagne une conférence
débat était organisé hier lundi à
l'université interâges à versailles
c'était en présence de leurs principaux
soutiens le maire de vélizy villacoublay
pascal thévenot ou encore valérie
pécresse la présidente de la région
un thème de la soirée qu'elle lutte
efficace contre la radicalisation et le
terrorisme
troisième rendez vous de ce genre qui va
se poursuivre jusqu'au scrutin en
octobre dans ce cycle de conférences que
l'on a lancé on veut montrer qu'on a une
droite qui réfléchit qu'est capable de
proposer des solutions et ne pas être
seulement dans la critique
là on passe au régalien avec la question
du terrorisme qui malheureusement est
encore d'actualité a frappé notre pays
encore récemment en plein coeur de paris
est donc le but c'est vraiment d'ouvrir
les échanges d'échangés avec la salle
c'est important c'est de ne pas être là
à parler voilà dans un seul une seule
direction mais d'écouter aussi nos
militants et tous les talents qu'on a
dans cette fédération leur donner la
parole
demain mercredi dans ce journal nous
recevrons l'autre candidat à la
présidence de la fédération l ère pierre
bédier le président du conseil
départemental des yvelines
lui on le reçoit tout de suite c'est
farid rachid bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
le président et fondateur de
l'association le sv élan de solidarité
vélizy alors ça la fait plus d'un an
avec votre association oeuvre pour les
sans abri nous avions déjà reçu en
septembre déjà prenons quelques
nouvelles de sv une nouvelle qui n'est
pas très bonne d'abord les locaux de
votre association ont été ravagés par
les flammes début mai quelle est
l'ampleur des dégâts bah malheureusement
les dégâts sont des gros dégâts
matériels
on a en fait tout perdu tout ce qu'on a
pu constituer pendant toute cette année
de travail que ce soit avec les
adhérents ou les bénévoles sont partis
en fumée
c'est à dire une repartait à zéro
finalement oui on repart à zéro et mis à
part tout ce côté m'as tu as tout
l'espoir qu'on donne aux sans abri et à
la jeunesse qui nous permet à nous de de
sensibiliser sur la précarité qui est
aussi parti en fumée on va parler bien
sûr du bilan de cette année oui on en
sait plus sur l'instant dit c'est un
incendie volontaire
malheureusement on va plus axé sur un
incendie criminel
actuellement l'enquêté est en cours et
l'opg puis le commissaire albert sabin
fait tout pour retrouver les auteurs de
ce crime odieux en fait vous l'avez dit
presque où tout est parti dans cet
incendie est ce que ça ça met un coup au
moral ou au contraire ça ça renforce
dans son idée de d'agir pour pour les
sans abri ben moi je vous cache pas que
sama
me un grand grand coup au moral au début
parce que quand on vous appelle à 4
heures du matin pour vous signaler que
votre local est en feu sincèrement c'est
limite choquant mais ça nous donne là ça
nous donne vraiment le l'opportunité et
l'envi et la force de vouloir vraiment
tout reconstruire et ennuyant plus alors
ça fait plus d'un an que vous venez en
aide aux sans abri en septembre vous
aviez lancé l'opération pièce rouge pour
collecter des petites pièces de monnaie
pour financer vos actions financer le
matériel
une opération qu'on peut comparer à
celle des pièces jaunes qui est qui est
plus connu huit mois après quel est le
bilan de cette action est ce que les
yvelinois les habitants de vélizy se
sont mobilisés pas déjà avant tout on a
eu la chance de pouvoir avoir un don de
véhicules fait par les pompiers des
yvelines qui nous a permis de pouvoir se
déplacer une fois par semaine donc
pouvoir être au coeur de l'action
sociale dans les rues de la région mais
aussi pouvoir voir que les légendes
vélizy était sensible à nos actions et
bien évidemment apporter leur
contribution en mettant en place chacun
à mener sa petite monnaie pour pouvoir
mener à bien nos missions c'est à dire
acheter les kits hygiène vous parliez de
ces véhicules offerts par vos collègues
veilleux rappelons la paire précisé mais
vous êtes également sapeur-pompier
ça fait chaud au coeur que ses collègues
viennent en aide à l'association
ben ce qui fait réellement chaud au
coeur c'est un mes collègues
nous nous aide mais c'est surtout le
l'élan national puisque ce soit les
pompiers de paris des pompiers de la
région ile de france
on voit les pompiers de france nous
m'ont encouragé à me relancer assez
rapidement comment s'est déroulé à
l'hiver pour l'association et les
maraudes que vous avez pu mener sur le
terrain et ballet de déplacement on a la
chance de avec ce véhicule et tous les
les la jeunesse parce qu'il faut savoir
que met à parler des placements
solidaires on a mis en place des actions
de sensibilisation auprès des jeunes
donc en fait concrètement on achète des
kits hygiène et tous les jeunes autour
de nouba mettez en place s'est quittés
après on les distribue et avec
différentes personnes de vélizy voilà
vous avez été soutenu par la ville de
vélizy les pompiers on l'a dit plus
récemment également le magasin auchan de
les visiteuses qui a également apporté
sa pierre à l'édifice et bien à ma
grande surprise le mal causé par cet
incendie a montré que beaucoup de
personnes étaient solidaires notamment
on va revenir ce centre commercial
vélizy 2 le directeur d'auchan la
direction des pompiers
beaucoup d'entrepreneurs aussi ont
proposé leurs services pour nous
reconstruire
donc pour moi c'est tout simplement une
force supplémentaire pour pouvoir
rebondir amplement et pour rebondir
justement vous avez besoin de quoi
aujourd'hui
quels sont les dons que l'on peut faire
à l'association au début il ya plusieurs
étapes la première étape c'est l'étape
des assurances en fait ils vont mettre
en place
les pertes occasionnées par cet incendie
et après je vais solliciter les
entreprises pour nous aider nous à
mettre en place des grosses actions de
de solidarité c'est à dire que dans les
prochains mois il y aura de nouvelles
actions très rapidement c'est ça l'idée
oui en fait je peux même vous l'annoncé
un mon projet c'est de pouvoir mettre en
place en fait le premier salon mobile
100% électrique pour les sans-abri en
fait qui va permettre au tour de de ce
mobile de coiffure rendre toute la
dignité à ces personnes qui sont dans la
rue et ça ça va passer par notamment des
entreprises telles que le centre
commercial vélizy 2 et on précise que
pour venir en aide à l'association pour
obtenir plus d'information peut être
devenir bénévole aussi vous pouvez vous
rendre sur la page facebook élan de
solidarité
vélizy qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci rachid sfar gars merci morhino
alexia vous président et fondateur de
cette association le sv élan de
solidarité d'elithis est d'après
maupassant elle a abrité la plus belle
histoire d'amour du 19e siècle entre la
cantatrice pauline viardot et l'écrivain
russe ivan tourguéniev en ruine la villa
viardot à bougival a été retenue pour
bénéficier du loto du patrimoine le lieu
construit en 1830 fait partie des 18
sites nationaux sélectionné c'est le
seul en ile-de-france est la demeure
figurera donc sur les billets de loterie
qui seront vendus 15 euros l'unité en
septembre et les bénéfices du tirage
iront à la fondation du patrimoine qui
aura pour mission de redistribuer les
gains aux différents monuments une
enveloppe une enveloppe de 15 à 20
millions d'euros au total
un loto du patrimoine imaginait parlera
stéphane bern
écoutez le au micro de michael ni
d'euros ces sites emblématiques sont des
sites ambassadeurs qui me permettent de
montrer que toutes les régions de france
y compris l'outre-mer sont concernés
mais aussi toutes les typologies de
patrimoine patrimoine château patrimoine
religieux patrimoine vernaculaire
patrimoine archéologique et les maisons
dit luce comme la maison pauline viardot
à bougival savez sur tous les sites et
bien la majorité sont des sites qui
appartiennent à des collectivités
locales des mets des petites communes
qui n'ont pas les moyens
quand ils ont trois cents habitants de
restaurer un monument qui qui leur coûte
un million et demi par exemple donc là
on est là pour les aider et j'espère que
ce loto patrimoine
rencontre un grand succès et ce lotois
du patrimoine doit aider à financer les
travaux de restauration consolidation
d'aménagement des abords et de
l'intérieur de la villa un chantier
estimé à plus de 2 millions d'euros
autre patrimoine à préserver il n'est
pas bâti c'est la nature l'environnement
qu'il convient de protéger pour ce faire
des actions d'information et de
sensibilisation exemple une deuxième
semaine du développement durable est
organisée à voisins le bretonneux pour
en parler une nouvelle invitée m'a
rejoint en plateau catherine atteint
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes la deuxième
maire adjointe de voisins-le-bretonneux
en charge de la culture de
l'événementiel et de l'environnement
alors cette semaine du développement
durable elle a débuté samedi dernier
avec un village développement durable
elle se poursuit cette semaine donc
jusqu'à samedi prochain le 2 juin à des
conférences ateliers projections sont
notamment au programme c'est la deuxième
édition de cette semaine pourquoi la la
proposer à nouveau d'ici noir parce que
le développement durable c'est une
oeuvre de longue haleine c'est une
oeuvre de sensibilisation de nos
habitants et on ne peut pas faire ça de
manière ponctuelle en une seule fois et
ensuite l'oublier donc c'est pourquoi
nous voulons que cette semaine du
développement durable qui s'inscrit dans
la cadre des semaines européennes du
développement durable soit un événement
récurrent sur la ville de voisins même
si bien sûr nous faisons des actions
tout au long de l'année il nous a paru
important en fait de sensibiliser les
habitants en faisant une semaine
consacrée au développement durable à
cette période ci de l'année et que ça
devienne pour eux une habitude en fait
cette semaine qui est donc vous l'avez
dit ponctuelle il ya des actions plus
large en faveur de l'environnement qui
sont menées toute l'année par par
voisins oui bien sûr évidemment la ville
de voisins qui gère donc ses parcs et
jardins s'inscrit dans la démarche zéro
phyto issu de la loi la baie donc
n'utilisons maintenant plus de produits
phytosanitaires dans toute la ville donc
ce qui nous a conduit à réfléchir sur
comment nous entretenons nos parcs et
jardins les fréquences de ton de la
transformation de massifs d'annuelles en
vivaces des fauchage tardif pour
permettre la biodiversité l'installation
de trois ruches au parc de la croix du
bois depuis
quelques années maintenant donc nous
avons des récoltes de miel de plus en
plus nombreuses
nous apercevons que nos abeilles vivent
très bien pour l'instant nous ne sommes
pas encore touché par le frelon
asiatique donc voilà et puis évidemment
sur tous nos bâtiments nous entreprenons
une rénovation et on regarde évidemment
tout ce qui est le côté thermique
énergétique
à chaque fois la favorisation aussi des
circulations douces donc piétonne et
vélo donc l'installation de deux
parkings vélos la proximité donc on a
des quantités d'actions en cours
donc nous mais non avec levi sinoe sur
cette semaine les objectifs on peut
l'imaginer c'est de donner toutes les
clés les bons réflexes au but chinois
pour que ça se poursuive au delà de
cette semaine qui utilisaient les bons
réflexes toute l'année exactement donc
c'était le but du donc 2 2 samedi
dernier à la croix du world nous avions
un village associatif donc nous avions
la lèque qui représente l'agencé locale
pour l'énergie et de cinquante ans
divine qui peut donner en fait aux
habitants de saint quentin des outils
pour mieux isoler leurs maisons réduire
leur consommation énergétique nous
avions jardin parce qu'on partage aussi
qui faisait un troc plantes nous avions
la ligue de protection des oiseaux
nous avions aussi le service de
l'agglomération en ce qui concerne les
tout ce qui est traitement et
valorisation des déchets d'accord avec
en fait comment comment trier ses
déchets et puis les préinscriptions pour
les composteurs pour diminuer en fait ce
qui part dans les poubelles tout
simplement il y aura d'abord il y aura
d'ailleurs demain mercredi une visite du
site donc le site de tri des déchets on
pourra voir l'envers du décor
complètement
et puis aussi lutter contre les idées
reçues et c'est vrai qu'on s'est rendu
compte à cette occasion qu' on ne savait
pas complètement comment quoi faire avec
des barquettes plastiques avec nos
aérosols avec nos enveloppes kraft pas
kraft a fondé avec sans fenêtre donc
c'est pas mal de se remettre un petit
peu en question puis de regarder tout ça
de près alors c'est un programme très
fourni jusqu'à samedi on va pas avoir le
temps de le détailler
qu'est ce qu'il faut retenir de ce
programme que c'est diversifié il ya
aussi bien des ateliers
une projection des projections au
programme des conférences également
alors demain après midi donc au parc
eugène fleuret au centre dans les villes
de voisins vous avez une après-midi
jardinage destiné plus particulièrement
aux enfants avec la participation des
jardiniers de la ville et de
l'association villes vertes dont les
enfants vont pouvoir planter remettre en
état le jardin potager partagé de la
ville mais aussi fabriquer des bougies
en cire d'abeille un petit clin d'oeil à
nos abeilles de la croix du bois même si
c'est pas la cire qui proviennent là
mais bon voilà vous avez le soir une
projection du film de jacques perrin
océans en salle du conseil municipal
vous avez le lendemain la salle numéro
est une des ateliers pour pouvoir
produire ses propres produits ménagers à
base de produits très simples tels du
vinaigre blanc 2000 carbonate de soude
le soir jeudi soit vous avez une
conférence en salle du conseil municipal
sur l'agriculture périurbaine donc en
fait comment favoriser également la
biodiversité et puis là la culture très
proches de nos habitations pour limiter
le nombre de kilomètres entre nos
aliments les aliments que nous
consommons et et nos assiettes c'est
très exactement réalisée par le centre
alfred de vigny donc c'est un rallye en
famille avec diverses questions sur
l'environnement qui va se dérouler dans
la ville de voisins tout l'après-midi la
1ère questions très pratiques pour
participer à toutes ces animations il
faut s'inscrire il faut s'inscrire soit
en mairie soit auprès du centre alfred
de vigny en ce qui concerne le défi
enfin le rallye les familles et pour
plus d'information d'ailleurs le site
internet de la ville de
voisins-le-bretonneux s'affiche en bas
d'écran merci à catherine atteint
d'avoir été avec nous il faut un prix
rappelle deuxième maire adjointe de
voisins-le-bretonneux et vous êtes donc
en charge de la culture de
l'événementiel et de l'environnement
comme chaque mardi le portrait de la
rédaction ce soir nous allons à
guyancourt au coeur de la ville existe
une oasis un jardin où se mêlent plantes
exotiques fruits et fleurs rares cela
fait 25 ans que de faux s'en occupe
présidente de l'association jardins
passions partage elle a ouvert à camille
lambert maintenant varaldo et nicolas
landry est les portes de son petit
paradis végétal
là c'est un cas qui claquent been
plaqueminier
là après produit beaucoup beaucoup de
fruits une centaine par an et la voyez
là il ya plein de fleurs la console un
convoi on va plein de boutons la voyez
cet arbre scellant des premiers plants
et parang de faux il y à 25 ans au
retour de la belle saison son jardin se
réveille les bourgeons commencent à
pointer les fleurs éclosent et les
abeilles et libellules reviennent chaque
jour c'est un enchantement pour cette
habitante de guyancourt c'est la verdure
ça fait changer d idée qu'on arrivait
dans le jardin bon on oublie tôt au
jardin devient pour sa venue pour reste
deux trois heures on voit pas le temps
passer
même sous la pluie on quand on y va on
reste on re cp décollé de la banane y
est nénuphar ou légumes une centaine de
variétés de plantes différentes
cohabitent ici et lui permettent de se
nourrir mais son amour pour ses protégés
l' empêche parfois de les cueillir
l'avait gardé la belle salade
normalement il faut les chalets les
manger elles sont presque trop haut trop
grosse déjà mais ça me fait de la peine
depuis que je veux pas trop couper cette
passion du jardinage
anglais souhaité la transmettre au plus
grand nombre d'abord membre des
jardiniers de france pendant une
quinzaine d'années elle a créé sa propre
association jardin passion partage il ya
cinq ans on fait souvent l'habitude du
jardin quand je vais voir quelqu'un qui
a un jardin même petit mais bien
organisé bien bien présente et bg-12
mention pour ouvrir son jardin et c'est
comme ça que c'est convivial et les gens
sont d'accord voilà on fait les visites
surtout c'est le partage l'échangé le
partage surtout surtout ça on cherche à
échanger entre nous à se donner des
idées à s'entraîner aussi aujourd'hui
130 adhérents font partie de
l'association sensible à l'écologie à la
protection de l'environnement en
organisent et participent aussi des
animations lors de la semaine du
développement durable de
voisins-le-bretonneux atelier cuisine
son autre passion
il nous donne un panier avec les légumes
dedans d'après c'est à nous débrouiller
pour faire des plats une entrée un plat
un dessert celle des jardins ses lacets
légumes pour la somme et qu'on a planté
qu'on a sauté du cocan s'agrandit et
après bon ben on va on va transformer
ces légumes l'a1 est plat il des moments
de partage pour retrouver des amis comme
elisabeth qu'elle connaît depuis 9 ans
j'ai rencontré plus d'une fois dans la
cuisine d'ailleurs que la pratiquement
on a fait des ateliers ensemble et puis
ça marche bien où l'on tient en ramène
du monde et puis bon la cuisine très
bien elle est très sympathique en plus
les curieux pourront aller visiter son
petit havre de paix nous samedi de juin
avec le musée de la ville une découverte
historique et botanique
avant de se quitter du sport ce week-end
le rugby-club de versailles a réussi un
coup de maître qualification en quarts
de finale du championnat de france
honneur
ils sont venus à bout d'une autre équipe
yvelinoise l'entente maisons laffitte
saint germain en laye poissy le score
très adroit dans une ambiance électrique
le résumé de cette rencontre ne l'est
pas - il essayait michael mier d'euros
et nicolas landry
la célébration était au niveau de la
décharge d'énergie déployée par le rc
versailles ce dimanche les joueurs de la
cité royale se qualifier en quarts de
finale du championnat de france honneur
après une victoire dans le derby vinoy
contre le mlf gp ce qu'en finale a trait
à trois gros match on savait on a on n'a
pas forcément réussi à produire ce qu'on
aurait voulu produire aujourd'hui on a
beaucoup subi et on allait chercher avec
les tripes parce que c'était vraiment
dur quand cette équipe de maisons
laffitte car elle achète une victoire
acquise en grande partie grâce à une
défense resserrée dans les derniers
mètres qui a perturbé leurs adversaires
j'avais récupéré des vidéos donc je
savais un peu comme jouer donc on avait
mis en place un système de défense la
carac a fonctionné avec des avec des
couloirs une défense de fer qu'il faudra
revoir au prochain tour les versets y
affronteront chalon sur saône une des
meilleures équipes de division honneur
est candidat au titre
versailles devrait aller battre pour
continuer à rêver de la montée lorsqu'on
ce qu'on vaut face à une grosse équipe
sans pression aucune soit là pour le
coup on n'a vraiment pas la pression
donc allez voir ce qu'on vaut quant à
face à des semi pros on va dire
on sait que c'est très compliqué on
verra en fonction des résultats il ya
des tapis verts etc
on ne peut pas vraiment calculé sur les
phases finales après on prend les
matches les uns après les autres on aura
un gros match en deux semaines
on sait qu'il ya un énorme est mort ce
qui va nous attendre
là on n'est pas morts on est encore là
et tant qu'on est là il va falloir bien
retaper la rencontre sera programmée le
dimanche 10 juin sur terrain neutre
entre la bourgogne et l'yonne les
supporters vers ses yeux rêve déjà d'un
nouvel exploit de leurs protégés et on
suivra bien sûr la suite des aventures
des versaillais c'est la fin de ce set 8
journal le replay est à consulter sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile tv 78 très bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]